[Musique]
en direct live cptaq bradley pour chanel
dose tu es la meilleure dans les faits
divers des incendies les carambolages
les émeutes du black friday au centre
commercial
les responsables sont furieux de devoir
prendre autant de risques j'appelle ça
faire son boulot de reporter kate ça
suffit tu m'entends
rassure l'appel d'une femme dans le sud
du bronx est dit avoir trouvé un sac
plein de billets de banque
elle est convaincue qu'il a été déposée
par un bon ça m'as tu fais un break sur
les événements show une femme trouve un
sac plein d'argent c'est même pas de
l'info croit pas à l'hypothèse du bon
samaritain j'ai pour principe d'être
toujours objective mais non
une personne nous observe et nous y en
ait
et je dois dire que j'ai vraiment du mal
à croire qu'une personne puisse faire
une bonne action sans rien attendre en
retour
ce ne sont pas des faux j'ai trouvé le
sac ce matin devant notre corps il a
laissé le sac juste là donc la semaine
dernière huit personnes ont trouvé 100
mille dollars selon leur taille leur en
fait on est là pour le banc de sable
une femme a créé un club anonyme de bon
samaritain est un gars qui passe à la
caisse d'une boutique à régler
anonymement les achats desdits clients
suivants moi j'ai commencé à couvrir
cette histoire j'étais sûr que non ça
m'avait un motif qu'ils étaient inavoués
maintenant il ya des personnes qui font
le bien autour d'elle
[Musique]
l'intérêt pour ce généreux donateur ne
cesse de croître les habitants ne
parlent plus que de sa générosité et de
où et quand le prochain sacs remplis
d'argent pourraient apparaître
certaines personnes disent que new york
est une ville difficile mais grâce aux
bons sam
je ne vois plus que des marques de
sympathie entre inconnus
bon samaritain nous inspire tous de
l'espoir les en ont besoin à notre
époque
c'est contagieux un peu comme les
miracles
la question qui nous préoccupe donc tous
à présent qui est cet homme au coeur
d'or
lalonde